it's you up with Nikki Glaser to guests
in the studio now two huge guests oh my
gosh Pete Holmes Judd Apatow welcome to
the show
I'd like to talk about blink for a
second I have blink 182 you do my eye I
don't like the fact that there's cameras
everywhere because there's things I want
to do that
I don't want seen on video so I assume
like the street where I live
everyone has cameras but what if I'm mad
at a neighbor and want to slash their
tires I could I not do that now I think
you still can you can that's what the
burlap sack is for that's true and you
can watch yourself do it later on
okay so there's I can still harass
people somehow ya know you can still be
the vandal that we know and love you
okay good
[Music]
judges is a real rascal it's built throw
bricks at corporations he's lit me on
fire more than one are you like a
prankster John and ring stir I would
never do it but I like the idea that I
could
I hate swear on this so yes you Oh Hank
hey Peter there's others package outside
for you I open the door there's nothing
you're a liar you're a dick and I
believed you you took advantage of my
open heart shame on you you know when
people prank people and they go oh and
I'm just kidding
I'll never forget when I didn't know you
were kidding stay with me forever and
and color the way I look at you and
interact with you the rest of my day
because I didn't trust you for that even
if you go you look ugly today just
kidding
that second I'm being like oh yeah Adam
saying I used to do this range back in
the day when we live together when we
were young kids
it bugged me so much which is he would
call me and he would try to he would
show interest in me in my life and and
and try to get me to open up about
something and then as soon as I got
emotional and opened up he would hang up
on me oh and he would do it all the time
and it was always like could he just
trick me into thinking it wasn't
happening I'd be like so what happened
with Wendy did you guys talk like did he
find out why she was so upset and then I
go you know I don't know we're just
struggling and then I just hear click
text me and I'll be like oh my god I was
just doing a show and they couldn't stop
talking about and he'll do that for like
30 minutes I'll be like I can't remember
I can't remember and then I'd be like
who has everything all right it was my
mother John Mayer I want that sweet may
or not your mother you want to hear that
mayor's a big fan uh I'm sure you've met
John Mayall what mayor's approval
I mean Val is up for it and Johnny go
ahead bring some pics because she's
gonna want to hear a song afterwards
got everyone once that mayor what is it
dude I understand his dream he's got the
one dangerous arm the one regular arm
you know you mean he's got rings like
Johnny Depp rings one of the Rings is
like around his neck I get it I'm not
even roasting them he's dreamy I was at
a charity event and they were they were
auctioning off John Mayer will sing your
bodies a wonderland right now to you
that's fine and so I didn't want it for
him to do it to my wife and so they put
a chair on the stage and this is on
YouTube if you want to see it and he
starts looking in my wife's eyes Oh No
and it was getting intense and then I
just got on stage and stood right behind
my wife all the young girls that love
John and think he's like their dream
boyfriend and I'm like you realize he's
having sex with tens of thousands of you
guys right he's like he's gonna whisk me
away no no he's not
they don't want to be whisk they just
want to be one of them I get out I take
it back take it back but I think you're
right there is something that like you
could you convince yourself no he would
just say that's right that's what I'm
yeah there's a fantasy especially with
younger people that are like no no I
could change I could tame the bad arm
it's like how I felt about Cheryl Tiegs
yes or Sheryl Crow Sheryl any of the
crows Russell no question mark on the
you up no because it's that you up
that's oh you're say it's declaratively
you better be up but it's also a you up
question but I'm presuming it's a guy
texting he doesn't even throw in
punctuation oh yeah yeah and we're going
baby we don't need punctuation it's just
that's just so disrespectful to not even
have a question mark with the you up yes
he's just giving it that little effort
it's less sexy when you're like married
and and it's it and you're sending it
you know to your husband or your wife at
6:30 in the morning and it's like you up
okay then can you drive the kids to
school today
I just had a baby so I'm constantly
checking if she's out because you check
if they breathe that's like a real thing
people are paranoid you get up to pee
and you're like oh everything's fine I'm
sure she's fine she's in her crib and
then you're like what if that's the time
yeah I got a check to be superdad it's a
real fear tempted to text your baby I
text my baby someday I remember when I
got a dog I was like I just want text
when I don't like you have that instinct
that you can't do you can't do I have a
joke in my new special about that if my
dog had a cell phone now to have 384
missed calls right now
and 7,000 text of the bone emoji and the
walk emoji you should get a phone for
your baby now text just all the time and
then one day she'll just be able to turn
on the phone and she'll be able to read
and she'll have years of your attack I
love going back through my baby booking
like reading funny things that I said
that my parents just had the wherewithal
to jot down in that moment my parents
called me Paul for the first four years
because they made up the name Paul are
you keeping track of the cute funny
things what are some that you said no I
mean our baby is only three months old
okay so not doing a lot she's she's yeah
three months nobody gradually thank you
I was just gonna say nobody gives a
about your baby that's what I've learned
that true rob riggle about and he's like
especially in LA he's like no I
understand you care not supposed to feel
that I thought we were supposed to keep
that to ourselves that we don't carry I
didn't know that you were you knew that
we know it's how long people will
pretend to like your baby when you show
them a picture you need to find other
new parents those are the only people
that maybe and all we want to do is look
at your baby and go not excuse you get
jealous to like your baby's very cute so
there's a part of you that's just like
it is I mean we kept saying gonna be
cute anyway that's so fun we kept going
like it's not just that's right this is
yeah people are telling you your baby
should model like that's I feel like the
general thing when I see we should model
like not model but it should be on
diaper bags she could she could move
some mashed up carrots there's also
there's that great Seinfeld but no one
wants to go to your wedding yes isn't
that great yeah I just want it I don't
know the whole bit just the premise
that's what I'm looking for in stand-up
comedy no one wants to go to your
wedding like a secret that you think
like we all thought the people getting
married didn't know that we all
don't want to go to your wedding yes he
outed us that's the greatest feeling you
can get at a static will show your baby
looks so much like you that it feels
impolite it really did she came out and
I was like oh no you're supposed to pass
but like a little slimy me came out and
I was just like well it's mine like it
was weird what as she's gotten
older she looks a little bit more like a
mom but I look like my wife oh yeah yeah
we're like twincest have you ever heard
of twincest apparently I know what I'm
into
and it's me I know I was like just throw
the dog a bone that's more comfortable
than me where I just I just like look
like a beast and it's just nothing and
then then the kids really hate if anyone
says they look like me like that there's
no bigger insult to them it's like what
that is why she looks beautiful
I've never been able to tell you this
but you're very beautiful they don't
want to take up the the Jewish goofy
side of their genetic heritage tell them
that Jewish goof bought this house my
dysfunction I don't know it's Kennedy my
dysfunction and my goofy appearance is
why I wrote those films because I'm
George
these Judaism is what brought the Cable
Guy from a romp into
a dark comedy I don't know I Kennedy
people do look like the people they end
up with or they start looking like them
like yes yes right I mean but it can go
both ways yeah I in all seasons there's
a lot I love about FAL and it does not
have to do with the very but what's that
every Instagram people like you fokin
yourself really post one of those 2018
2008 know things I didn't either I
couldn't find the worst part about that
is in the last 10 years I've completely
crumbled it's all fall apart so my wife
like we have like a wall of photos over
the years in the hallway and my wife
just looks the same for decades she's
like a female Paul Rudd or something and
I'm just losing hair and going gray and
falling apart and it's the stress of
being with a statuesque woman yes yes
it's your beauty but she's like you know
she's a healthy person and I'm not and
now she's just looking at me like are
you ever gonna get it together guys have
some like there's something going on
with you I've seen your face she's like
sweet fridge she said when we go out it
looks like an old weird man paper very
expensive Russian hooker prostitute
forgive me and pimp we always whenever
we go to restaurant sir
him so now be like don't cause pimps by
the way be like no we're parents they're
not like we are sellers of fine
nighttime evening style sex whatever we
go out to clubs or not we don't go too
close but like restaurants we always
look around and for some reason my wife
always thinks that the women are hookers
she's like I think that's a hooker with
that guy like she doesn't believe in the
couple must be a financial arrangement
yes and she's always sniffing that out
is that really happening in these places
have you ever done crowd work and
realized in the middle that the guys
were the prostitute no I have I've been
like hello sir that's your date she's
looking sparkly what's your name of
Mercedes
wait a minute like I'm moving on
[Music]
you